je suis christophe vergne le fondateur
et président de michael
liles coop notre activité et dans la
e-santé ce qu'on appelle la santé
numérique
[Musique]
nous travaillons sur une aide aux
professionnels de santé en oncologie
notamment dans la prise de décision
savoir que les professionnels ont
aujourd'hui de plus en plus de donner
d'informations à gérer et donc le métier
rendu plus difficile à la fois dans pour
une meilleure prise en charge des
patients mais également pour la
recherche clinique ou encore des
développements une intelligence
artificielle
[Musique]
nous avons développé à ce jour trois
outils le premier outil développé par
maicon est un tableau de bord pour les
rcp et ce tableau de bord permet de
visualiser les informations toutes les
informations critiques pertinentes
sur un patient donné qui va être
discutée dans le cadre de ces de ces
réunions un deuxième qui consiste à qui
est une interface patients qui consiste
à capter les symptômes du patient qui
est en traitement et un troisième en
fait qui est une interface pour
l'infirmière de pratique avant ces cas
là on va dire sorte de monitoring
d'outils de monitoring du patient avec à
la fois le plan thérapeutique qui a été
choisi et la remontée des symptômes de
ses patientes
le premier outil est validée et
commercialiser
les deux autres sont surtout aujourd'hui
dans le cadre d'une dévaluation
académique que je citais à l'avant avec
les structures hospitalières en europe
la structuration des données et la
validation clinique des données que nous
que nous opérons
travers de la solution michael permet
d'aller sur d'autres marchés qui peuvent
en être plus sur la recherche clinique
où le développement de nouvelles
solutions en numérique et là en fait qui
ouvre le champ des possibles nous avons
quelques quelques discussions en cours
de ce point de vue là